no matter what happened in your life you
got a lot of love like I said despite
the color away from what happened people
love you man I just went up for the
slaughter at night want to be real
worried there yeah we had a good image
cheese like dog it was the best day of
my life
Mike Tyson was so [ __ ] coming you know
what you're doing right now I mean we're
having Britain the Mike Tyson today we
have a special guest man a New Yorker
man one two percent Tom Joey did talk to
us what's happening
so we the champ Mike Tyson straight from
Cuba 205 West 88th Street and [ __ ]
points beyond and then I ended up in
North Bergen New Jersey and because my
mother had a bar in Union City but yeah
you know Jersey City yeah I know Mario
Kosta know you're inside gym they're not
sitting all by Journal Square yeah yeah
yeah I used to go to junior high now I
went to Bob Harley's basketball camp
when I was a little kid he was a coach
you know there's two kids play for Duke
and he had a basketball camp there I
used to go to movie through there and I
got stabbed dad yeah the real crime here
if the neighborhood I live on the Sunset
Strip and I went and got high smoking
pot with my friends and some dude cut me
through a sweatshirt so [ __ ] tremendous
but it's great to be here with you
towards own buddy
great I Love You Man you know Mike and I
have a lot of similarities we both lost
our mothers at the age of 16 we both got
locked up
you've been its profit you get what's I
you have been a Spartan and Bronson your
kid was that Spofford Avenue
you know manners juvenile lockup no no
no
I was good as a juvie that was my [ __ ] I
was good as a Jew because I you and I
had something else in common we got
saved by an Italian man yeah
okay well I moved to New Jersey the
neighborhood man was karma and Bolzano
God rest his soul and he took me into
his house even though I was Cuban he had
three four other sons and one of the
sons died and I kind of replaced him
so whatever the sons got I got that
gives you a different type of feeling it
was the 70s ain't no ain't no speaker no
black do gonna walk into an attorney's
house
but they didn't look at it like that we
got saved by somebody Italian that's we
have so many similarities you know
you're from Brownsville in my early
years I enjoyed in the Bronx from Arthur
Avenue yeah I'm still [ __ ] kicked in
a jape represented like a [ __ ]
still the last American slices are not
the Avenue now everybody knows that in
this country but those in Italian it's
just a pleasure to be with somebody who
understand Mike Tyson was the king of
New York you know how that is to be the
king of New York walk the walk talk the
talk the king of New York
thank you brother he got the throne by
Tony Soprano yes I'm saying it just
happened I met him once you met him once
yeah yeah I'm James I was in golf games
Gandolfini a girl for a minute one how
was he
he was a very decent man he said when
would that movie I wouldn't that movie
he didn't even see the hangover that
movie out that's so funny
that's classic actor just so deep in
your art yeah that was just dumb listen
he left us all too soon yeah yeah
definitely all do they all do you know
we don't get to say goodbye or something
you always feel bad you know yeah but
back to Mike no I've been a fan since
day one the first time I saw you throw
up in fact I got to talk to you about
some you owe me $250 from July of 87
because I bought an eight ball and I was
working this chick you were fighting
Spinks and I'm like
sitting and I was working that I had 15
rounds to working but you knocked the
[ __ ] out in 58 seconds oh man how
little girlfriends took her back and
there I am with the safe bought a hard
dick how do you get eight balls oh
you're 28 you get a hard start now and
try to get your mother-fucking snake
charmer gonna work man god I always
wanna know that secret man how did you
get Holley in the 80s you could get your
hair caught on coke then then they
started putting hairspray and I always
had viagra and all that's a killer oh my
god I never divide I'm scared yeah but
hey I knocked my wife up at 50 yeah he
did so I'm good yeah she was shorter -
yeah 15 that's amazing open dope like a
[ __ ] no other drugs I knocked
her up amazing can you believe that God
and that's where he to him she was 32
yeah Wow first child 32 my aunt had a
had my cousin at 45 so it can happen
really yeah CEO Vaughn's father was 72
72 whose father Theo von you gotta get
that [ __ ] in here oh yeah
stories - yeah he's amazing he's amazing
but Theo had him when he was 70 his
father had him when he was 72
God man a newborn a Spanish dude that's
bad [ __ ] that Spanish firm you know
naughty open the [ __ ]
casket you know I'm saying you got a
Puerto Rican with good genes
you jerk them off in the casket boom you
got twins
did I couldn't imagine being 72 and
having a newborn I was 20 I was 24
whatever we had our daughter man I was
[ __ ] when a [ __ ] trip that no man and
knock mum when my wife came and I was
with her for 13 years and she came and
she goes you knocked me up and I was
like [ __ ] closed the door hey think
about it for a little while and [ __ ] now
I'm very happy you know yeah I was happy
so God works in mysterious ways man no
doubt man you know it's funny as with
all the things we did were talking about
juvy like I mean you were badass
[ __ ] yeah I was doing [ __ ] but I
was keeping it on the down-low and I
knew too many people that get arrested I
be I became a felon after 17 when I got
busted at the age of 25 and I did two
years I came out into the halfway house
and I was still doing my [ __ ] and some
dude and in the prison he was in there
for murder and his wife and the mailman
this [ __ ] called a federal rap
because he was a mailman but he was the
prison librarian and he used to listen
to me talk constant on one of the nights
of the week they did movie night in
prison and the projector would always
break and I worked in the kitchen so I
had I knew everybody I worked in the
kitchen I was the stock clerk so I had
connections in there I was given the
bodybuilders extra meat I knew where the
extra cheese was you know and they would
say when the projector would break that
will go cube or go up there and say some
[ __ ] the brothers would go cube but get
the [ __ ] up there and say some [ __ ] and
I would go up then goof on the brother
you know I'm saying like I would do a
stand-up because I would sit behind the
prison line when they were feeding
prisoners and check out everything and
they'd be feeding them the food and
whenever they gave you like [ __ ] on
shingles what's that [ __ ] [ __ ] beef on
right yes that [ __ ] is net whenever they
gave all that type of [ __ ] I asked them
discuss the watery yeah we stand in the
back and as the brothers walked in first
I would go
don't do it
and they knew not to eat the [ __ ] so
then we had little prison dudes it was
an Italian dude that would make nachos
with a [ __ ] iron cook iron he would
took the [ __ ] guts out and he was
sticking the bucket and put a piece of
cheese in there at 8:00 in the morning
and by 6 o'clock the cheese would melt
and he would cut jalapenos up and there
was an American dude who made tacos so I
would tell him not to eat and I thought
they thought it was kind of funny the
way I said it so they would throw me up
on this table and I would just crack
jokes on the prisoners it was like
ninety-two prisoners is a prison camp
and I didn't know I was doing stand-up
my awesome and one day the prison
librarian was a nerdy dude and we were I
was a smoking dope in there cuz they
were piss testing you for him and I
would do acid from time to time and we
would stay up all night the guards ago
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you - we'd
be talking outside and [ __ ]
so tell me tell me this do you ever
think about like where you're at now and
what he's been do you experiencing but
your friends that died you never seen
you succeed it oh my god you just gave
me [ __ ] goose bumps I know we got
here when I start ever thought dude as
they think we were with them in the
streets we said happened now we're here
when I started comedy in 91 I did good
for the first two years and I went back
to New York City in 93 and a kid who
took me and would drive me to the gigs
was a dude that reminds me of you
his name was Darren ray go this
[ __ ] was shooting steroids when
we were 16 he would go into clubs I
would tell him take your shirt off and
do push-ups and he would just start
doing push-ups at the disco and without
a shirt on in 82 83 he was just crazy
and I left for a while when I came back
10 years later he was crazier Mike you
know how we get this dude was working at
the airports
one night I bumped into him two weeks
before he died he told me he goes what
are you doing nah he goes I'm a
bodyguard for a Chinese dude because all
I got to do is get him high he goes we
do ketamine we do this we do that we do
this but we have a drink but at the end
he goes we never drink because that'll
[ __ ] up your liver you know but he
used to pick me up this guy was a
gangsta he would pick me up and dry
drive me to comedy shows and watch me
and encourage me like you can't even
fathom this so this is a barren there's
damn Rago there's a picture him on my
wall I have a picture of him on my
ancestors shrine I have an ancestor
shrine all the [ __ ] I lost
along the way from Anthony Bolzano the
Dominic's Pesci how to all the kids that
I grew up with my mother my father my
one of my teachers the dude who took me
out of New York who took me to Boulder
Colorado and showed me to get me out of
New York and I old 50,000 the he died
and I got all their pictures and I put
Apple glasses of water that's what
you're doing you're Cuban and every
Monday you light a candle you fill the
glasses and you thank them for guiding
you through this [ __ ] life you know
why me why not the other guy that was
smarter than me had more money than me
we're cooler than me and anybody thought
they were the guys and they want to die
and I getting locked up for life how
come me I wasn't really the guy that a
Gupta everybody was supposed to make it
yeah I ask myself that every [ __ ] day
well I'm sitting there at 6 o'clock at
night and I'm eating dinner with my wife
and my little girl saying prayers I sit
there and I go if these two knew the
things I did you know I'm saying like I
questioned looked for a long time for
about two years until I shot the Netflix
degenerates I went through a hard period
in my life
a couple of years ago because I couldn't
accept what was going on people coming
up to me saying I changed that life
[ __ ] I robbed the can of coins one time
out of a carve-out you know those
[ __ ] cans they say donate the blind
kids donate the blind kids one time I
was dying yeah one time I went to carve
out I took whatever was in there was
$7.00 Mike and Here I am now at the
Comedy Store every [ __ ] night doing
comedy with Joe Rogan and Whitney
Cummings in Italy and [ __ ] Jeff Ross
and I look at myself and I go what the
[ __ ] listen you know I'm coming from a
place that where we came from what we
we only internalize who we are and we
think that we're nothing but we don't
think these guys did what we did and
it's in our mind like say say we know
somebody that killed somebody we've seen
somebody got didn't kill to something or
we're the cause of it you know I mean
somebody may have been picking on us I
tried to abuse this and we went they
tell a friend and a friend came back and
killed him you know that's just how it
is in New York and so we think though i
thought when i worthy of this cuz we're
scumbags every day of my life i you know
question how the [ __ ] I got here you
know in the seventh grade I got a GED
I'm a felon and I'm a Cuban that can't
play baseball I got nothing going for me
I got my GED only because I was going to
go to prison and if you get your high
school diploma day not two points off so
you end up going to a lower that's why I
wasn't putting I said he gets a GED they
get it's about failed damn GED so I said
let's try this kid let's go to the drug
counseling and pick these drug tests
into this program it's funny because I
[ __ ] my drug counselor I was in the
halfway house it was as bad as counsel
when I got out she used to piss test me
and I was putting I was pulling my I'm
uncircumcised so I was full pull the
skin back on my dick I was snorting coke
like a [ __ ] and I said what
cleans up your piss pool cleaner so I
would take pool clean and grind it down
on a cheese fries clean pool cleaners
those pills are you putting the [ __ ]
beer and they called around the water I
would shave that down I would pull the
skin of my dick back huh I would
sprinkle poutine on my dick get over and
put like a little bread tie at the end I
would go take a piss and I would pull
the skin back and the pool cleaner we're
going to the past and I would just go
boom and one time I put radio in that
moment but the dude couldn't catch what
I was doing they knew I was [ __ ] up
the machine mic but they couldn't catch
it so they sent the white chicken one
day
and I'm sure I would jerk off outside a
little bit to get my dick hard and I was
going there with this Cuban egg roll and
I [ __ ] me and [ __ ] with a hammer so I
get out of the halfway house I move on
with my life I got into comedy and I'm
I'm delivering Chinese food but slinging
coke and doing comedy at the same time
so if Mike wanted coke I would go Mike
don't call the Chinese restaurant order
an egg roll and I'll deliver it and at
least I can blame it on the Chinese
people because it was in the bag like a
fortune cookie so one day I knocked on
the door and who answers the door the
drug counselor but to boot she was she
was cute she had a nice breast she had a
nice body but the only prominent was she
had a leg like with a limp and it was
like a mystery so nobody talked to the
[ __ ] we went out we started swapping
sprint I started fingering her I laid it
down and what I did was I pulled the one
leg off the ones leg but I didn't even
pull the one the gene off the other leg
I just left a mystery I put my hammer in
her mouth and it was one of those long
comes when it's like man just looking at
you I wasn't trying to jerk off then I
was trying to get muscles I was 33
trying to get the blue finish it oh my
god I never saw her again she gave me
like an $8 tip and that was it I never
saw her again
I forget what her name was but who gives
a [ __ ] god bless you well you [ __ ] your
drug houses you got Prague in the
halfway house I was slinging in the
halfway house and Mike I was
loan-sharking cuz the rent was $75 and
you had to pay it on Thursday or you
couldn't get out when I got to the
halfway house that's when I went [ __ ]
nuts
I had the coke hidden in the [ __ ]
thing and I was selling the half way I
you can't believe like that I'm the same
person today
that's right now when they get mad at
the governor or even at that Judge for
something that did 30 years ago you
really can't get mad at that because I
was a completely different person I was
a complete change as a human being we
adapt every couple of years that we say
to ourselves we can act that way in
so I can't believe when Mike original
question was how do you feel how the
[ __ ] do you think I feel I [ __ ] my
drug counselor you know I had no respect
for nothing and it wasn't my fault it
wasn't that in respect people it was the
70s in New York that gave us this
feeling of invincibility
and I'm not a New York now I'm not the
type of dude that says New York Pizza
New York bagels I don't talk about that
[ __ ] but the heart that New York had in
the 70s set me out and then go into
North Bergen and hooking up with people
from Hoboken that Italian heart from
Hoboken gave me this you can't kill me
feeling like I got a nice neighborhood
or now it's a real nice [ __ ] [ __ ]
nice but the 50s and 40s it was kind of
weird towards the Italians so the
Italians that came out of Hoboken had a
fight so when I moved to North Bergen I
was surrounded with these guys that had
moved on up from Hoboken so I got that
heart from them
plus my Cuban heart Plus that thing that
New York had in the 70s that going to
42nd Street when you're 13 and avoiding
drum buying drugs for the first time and
they were fake drugs he had watch that
you don't get caught by the police
how many times did you walk on one of
those x-rated shows
let's sit on a hookers lap now a 14 yes
no listen this is the thing right you
were any one of these we're gonna run
these porn places right cuz I'm we did
with Robin all day we can't go home cuz
we're gonna sleep in the movie theaters
right but we got money and you're
sleeping and next thing you know you see
some guy comes in he sits in the front
you think he's watching movie you fall
off you wake up and he's in a seat
closer and then he falsely begin you
wake up he's right next to you oh wow
some [ __ ] freaky guy balls [ __ ] bro
well I went with little kid then we all
know these [ __ ] freaks dogs [ __ ] bro
one old CD I would go to and like East
Orange New Jersey on Sunday nights my
buddy got on a kick to go out there
and I never forgot I went up there one
time on a Sunday night and every time
you go to the bathroom a guy would just
mysteriously pop up next to you in the
urinals and next to you and look at you
he was like 40 so you get to see that
side we got we lived in with the whole
thing with Sir Robin for yeah come on
come have a sister for you come on my
god the whole thing to rob his [ __ ]
arm this [ __ ] um what do we call it
at the tricks Rob the tricks Rob the
tricks get the money there was a part
where I grew up Hudson County Park and
in like the summer of AD we found out
that if you stood out there guys that
would get drunk like all the guys would
come over and they'd look for people to
suck your dick we were coming home from
Judas Priest concert and we seen these
young guys out there and cars would pull
up and it was like a trick like where's
the George Washington Bridge and they
would go that way and the car would turn
around and the guy would get in it
so we devised a system where we get a
guy put like shorts on him with a nice
wife beater shirt on with a little
paddle and you put a little ball then
the guy would get the guy out of the car
no let me suck it that under the tree
and then they would take him under the
tree that's wrong I'm free yeah he would
kick them take their water run they
couldn't go to the cops yeah my
neighborhood has a hole right well
Bergen got so good at it that each
neighborhood had representatives that
would go down there and had that piece
and there was one neighborhood 64/3
field they had a kid that was so good
he'd make the [ __ ] take him to
their house and then he would call you
from there I'm over here making a girl I
got the guy tied up like that's how good
we were [ __ ] kids man we were 16 17
it was a different [ __ ] world you
have no matter of you know it was like
nobody you know this we got locked up it
was better than being home you know I
mean you had just snagged um they gave
you a snack that night three three meals
they treat you good gave me cookies and
milk
crazy dude I never wonder how old are
you I'm my 56 I just recently turned 50
to 53 yeah we walked past each other
yeah
sure I'm sure and I when I was a kid I
had a my mother had the bookmaking
operation in the Bronx and then we moved
to 118 Street it's in in Harlem but then
they have satellites on South action in
honey yeah but Saturday is the big day
for numbers so you have to develop
satellite offices and they would have an
office in bed-stuy that would have liked
a little bodega that would call the
numbers into them and we were paid to
walk around the neighborhood and look
the different type of cars like that
said they would give us like 40 bucks on
the sandy down and is jam packed jam
people so if you thought you had a run
back and tell him there's two guys in
the car all you did was walk around the
neighborhood all what does that mean
it's like a lookout you're like a
lookout and then there was these guys
are in the neighborhood yeah like this
cops in the neighborhood oh there's a
car down the block with weird plates and
a guy sitting there by himself right
they would give you like 40 bucks to
just walk around the neighborhood run
their marriage go get them ham and
cheese sandwiches and then that four
o'clock when the number comes out the
Brooklyn number cuz there's three
numbers there's the Brooklyn number the
New York number I didn't know which
comes out enough yeah when you look at
the total Mutual of the track and the
Daily News when you open up the The
Daily News you look at this there's
always the track they always give you
only in New York do they give you the
[ __ ] track results in what the track
made so the track handle is what the the
last three numbers is the number of the
day so you can bet that number you could
better buy the number and you know
neighborhoods were Mike Mike came from
where my mom had these places set up
people have a dream they have a job but
they have a dream whenever try to tell
your family know that wasn't a number
three came out yeah yeah yeah know what
when you take the number there's a
receipt if you take a number face to
face I have a receipt that goes three
ways it's a white copy of pink copy and
a blue copy and you got initially before
you get going some slick [ __ ] to make
changes people would try and even on the
phone people calling or no you gave me a
ten
let's go to the tape recorder it's not a
bookie that doesn't tape his phone calls
they all check their phone calls so you
come back at them and go
you called them a 250 time or 300 hours
yeah so it's some slick [ __ ] always some
slick [ __ ]
it's insane I was born in New York in 87
st. Vincent's
lived in Brooklyn Park Slope look the
way Atlanta cabañal we were on 14 or 12
Street between 8th Avenue and Prospect
Park
I was already gone I was doing time in
87 no 87 was when I got in trouble
everybody was doing make mistakes and
the funny thing is Monday I posted the
picture of the guy I kidnapped in 1987
he came to my show this past weekend in
Tucson Wow I've been in touch with him
for about five years I apologized to him
like a man it was a drug rip Mike it was
uh he had two kilos of coke and I was
young I was stupid you know and I made a
mistake and with another guy and we
[ __ ] up and I did you know he didn't
even testify Mike he didn't testify the
other guy my partner in it testified
against me and then I plea bargain to
zero to six the judge gave me four with
a control and court he told me to
[ __ ] come back in another twenty days
and if I behaved myself he reduced my
sentence when they cut it the community
corrections and that's the hardest thing
I went through prison ain't hard
it's that Community Corrections that's
how they hang you because you can't do
[ __ ] mistake you made you can't be in a
bar your life is six to six you know
basically you have to live under a
strict life and even then like I said I
was and if your friends a felony been a
walkway by yes you can then I say by you
it's a hard life at that point but you
know what man I did it I paid my debt to
society you know I got divorced I
[ __ ] lost everything I started again
and the only thing I could think of was
comedy and I just wanted to be a regular
comedian and I wanted to hide and I
ended up in Los Angeles and the next
thing you know I was like Richard Gere
in office and a gentleman I had nowhere
else to go
Mitsy sure god rest her soul gave me
spots spots spots then a dude Joe Rogan
I put he came into my life he taught me
how to be a professional you know and
here we are 27 [ __ ] years later
calmly saved my life the other thing
about doing residence season the
greatest anything I just did Treasure
Island Friday was tremendous I really
liked them I did the South Point before
they were very nice also but it's time
to you know move on up a little bit I'm
56 I got one foot in the grave one a
banana peel life left in me so I still
do my little every two weeks on the road
I got the podcast I got the kids I gotta
talk to you about something real quick I
take my kid you know I'm Cuban and
Cubans are very proud of their boxes so
I take my kid hitting the myths and I
sent it to my uncle he's 80 and my uncle
came back he goes you tell that [ __ ]
teacher hers that we're distant cousins
a kid chocolate yeah so I know that part
of your [ __ ] genius is that you
watched a lot of tapes ain't nobody I
could tell you a story about a fight his
name is Lidia Sardinas Sardinia Sardinia
about it Sardinia you know Sardinia
means in Spanish Bethenny you know
Sardinia means one of those things are
you eatin prison sardines sardines yeah
so Sardinia yeah kid shop with Sardinia
when you're in New York and I was and I
lived in Union City is the second
biggest Cuban population in the country
a big shout-out to Lucio Fernandez and
wait before you got into a fight when
you were Cuban the first thing you told
them [ __ ] listen before we box
I just want you to know my cousin's kid
chocolate no no but it's a [ __ ]
Island warm cousins I did that's when I
really
I'm 40% African what I've been saying
that the fact that he was that popular
he was just really like that yeah
remember I watched a lot of films about
I thought I knew the man who was he was
magnificent
did he really fight 25 times in one year
I listen I wouldn't doubt it listen he
had a hundred on amateur fights in Cuba
and he was undefeated with like 85
knockout is that true
they said they redid it they our story
and what end he only had 50 they said
about kids drop Adhamiya not some things
nothing kid chocolate was very
promiscuous you know in the em he fought
I had a lot of disease like venereal
diseases and stuff I believe that's how
he died probably he got sick and stuff
he had 16 area diseases diseases legends
that I wrote that read and stuff and I
saw Ben I saw pictures of her mom I
believe it was on what year was it it
was sudden happening that you are
watched uncovered and I think after I'm
a look on YouTube see they showed
pictures of him and cue but I can eat it
like an 80 84 88 something to that
effect and he was he was this old
broken-down man but he was a magnificent
fighter he was so inspiration and for
fighters like Archie Moore and your
Armstrong because when they saw him
fight he was on he made more money than
the heavyweights me like $100,000 a
fight in one particular fight or
something like that and that's why he
was so popular but he loved him
everybody they may saw wasn't gonna make
songs about him
I'm Count Basie did songs about I'm kid
chocolate and stuff he was just a
magnificent sensation when he came to
America he moved to New York and you
know he was awesome he was falling Santa
Mario Brown and all those guys he was
just magnificent it's just that he got
sick did you watch a lot of tape on him
and everything I wasn't fighting for
Delabar but I wasn't for all those guys
that I'm here it was a magnificent
fighter man kid I mean for Tony Camden
Airy for all these guys he had listened
he had out probably hundred and fifty
fights
pro fights great fight very sensational
fight a very popular fighter one of the
most popular fighters and they had
people named they named themselves after
him too right
kid chocolate bata chocolate listen Ava
sardines when he came to harm when
cancer took over he was a very wealthy
guy kid chocolate but he took everything
and he died in Cuba Iran Castro took
everything this wealthy he had money
Castle took all the property and all the
cash out of the bank
you know they turn theory communist so I
guess that was basically there to shut
it down yeah it's funny how many
venereal diseases when Columbus went to
Cuba he brought back like he took
something
he brought then he went back and what
they brought back was sugar and syphilis
yeah see the room was where the culture
you go was a big syphilis [ __ ] hotbed
interest you know I tested hot for
syphilis a few times no biggie
I moved on [ __ ] it good all right now
I'm doing all right
I know [ __ ] but that was yeah well the
time you guys came up I'm just glad you
didn't get the the HIV on man thank God
no you know what I can't see needles God
God threw me a big blessing I can't see
needles so hmm I never I think I snorted
heroin maybe two times three times and I
liked it I'm not gonna lie to you but I
knew that it would be a problem I had
enough problems on my hands with the
addictions I already had so I left it
alone and I don't til this day I've been
clean 11 years from that white [ __ ]
devil amazing and I don't know how I did
it I woke up one day and that was it
there was no rehab there was no hugs I
looked at my girlfriend at the time and
I knew I didn't want her to find me on
the floor there's some people like you
were me we're born to find [ __ ]
on last week my friend Floyd
there's some people who want cut out for
that it'll change their whole life my
wife is from Tennessee good family I
didn't want her to fire me on the floor
and one day I just stopped
and I keep tarifa because it keeps my
mind back on the street and who the [ __ ]
I was that's the last thing I do because
it it's my teddybear Mike I started
smoking chocolate I in 1980 and you know
gold over the Gihon oh my god that's
Thai chocolate I updated STNG
we [ __ ] kill you so I always kept
marijuana I don't like the word sober
it makes people edgy people that live
sober they have to hide there's
something I don't like the word soul but
well I got to tell you something god I
just read in this book how to change
your mind by Michael Pollan it's all
about psychedelics and LSD and
psilocybin and he talks about in there
how one of the the main a a founder Bill
Wilson mm-hmm he had his they talk about
in the 12 steps they talk about having a
spiritual awakening bill had his
spiritual awakening in a guided trip on
this stuff called belladonna which was
like a hallucinogenic compound and he
was a huge believer in the idea that LSD
could cure alcoholism he was a big
believer in psychedelic so it kind of
blues blew my mind and then it too you
know because what it does these things
are different you know they they crush
our ego they show us all our trauma and
our pain and they help us forgive
ourselves you know Julie do you still do
any I know you've posted like jars of
[ __ ] mushrooms on on your Instagram
he's still funny it's funny when I we
were talking about mescaline we used to
get mescaline back in the day back in
the day a four way my mom died I started
doing acid maybe a year before my mom
passed but my mom passed was the reason
one of the reasons I'm still here is
because I wanted an acid [ __ ] tan for
like a year
mm-hmm you know I'm scared now that I
might have something because for a year
I did acid I would go home at night put
do a hit ass and listen to Black Sabbath
I would force myself and then my mother
died in 79 and an 80 the war came up
they do a song called mother
oh yeah and ASEAN has a song and this is
our mother please forgive us and I would
force those on myself and face my
reality I my mother was gone it took me
five years grief is the [ __ ] mother
[ __ ]
it took me basically from 79 to 84 to
basically realized when she was gone
even though they put her in the hole I
was there they would nights I would
still drive by my old house just to see
if they made a mistake and she got
caught at Yonkers Raceway in traffic and
just you know so the acid helped me deal
with it I hated I hate myself for doing
it what I did but one of the reasons why
I'm still here is because I faced my
[ __ ] well I think yeah yeah man I
think it's very therapeutic you know
they're they're coming out with more and
more studies about how these things are
helping people deal with depression
dying you know the most intense things
that happen in life you know and that's
what kind of blew my mind is that the 12
steps that he put together are really
the steps of a psychedelic trip you know
you surrender to something you realize
that you are in the hands of God
and you make an encounter with God and
oneness and we are all connected and
then you experience some sort of
inventory of seeing all the things that
you did wrong you know all of the trauma
that you caused in your life and then it
moves to making an amends for all of
that
you know and apologizing to those you
need to end yourself and finding
forgiveness for yourself you know my
biggest therapeutic thing is I love
smoking marijuana in the morning getting
stoned and just letting my hand do the
walking on a piece of paper hmm and I'll
write out two or three pages and then
later on that night I'll look at it and
then write what I'm thinking at that
point you know I think
like the writing yeah has always helped
me with the marijuana especially like
from like last night I got home for
Comedy Store 11:30 you're wired up you
just did two [ __ ] shows yeah
yelling screwed Jack talking about Jesse
Smollett you know what man listen I had
a Santeria godmother and I went to see
her in 1995 before I left New York and
she read my cards and on the way out she
goes do me a favor don't ever do
business with three people in 1985 the
last thing she said to me is don't you
it says right here don't do business
with three people in 1987 what did I do
I set up a kidnapping with another guy
and that I remember when I turned myself
in I kept seeing images of my god-mom
don't do business with three people
that's what Jesse smell that's all she
said he did business with three people
that's it and two could always turn on
you and that's exactly what I'd only one
get to keep a secret is two of them a
day that's it only dead men talk so it's
uh it's really weird that you saw what
went down
you can't believe it but I don't blame
it on Jesse somewhat I blame it on
depression and Hollywood puts on these
kids whether it's Hollywood makes us do
some [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] if you fall in
say that [ __ ] hole I think just
for like attention I know what the thing
is we want these people to love us you
want these people to give us jobs and
want to live our life happily ever after
and be the head sometimes be the head
[ __ ] on the team I'm gonna be the
baddest [ __ ] on the team I'm the
richest the baddest whatever it may be
you know I mean and then we forget um we
forget who we really are you know we get
lost in this [ __ ] cloud of success of
what we believe is success being
different from what we were you know
I've been dressed up hating who I wore
and I wanna be that person or that
person that that person helped me become
who I want to be why I don't want to be
involved with that person in one of my
life least always be that way
close the door my path to get out of the
thief you know I'm my parents and other
street workers and all that stuff so all
that stuff would make people know wanna
throw the old life away you know you
always have to believe who you are and
have to accept who you are you know mean
and be conscious you know I always pay
people helping my conscience supersedes
my color you know got no time it is out
here
you know I know people my experience in
life and meeting cus you know I wish I
would have met cusp is when I did the
longest yard that was as I was shooting
it I got smoke blown up my ass and when
the movie came out nothing happened and
that was one of the darkest times in my
life and about a year and a half later
is when I quit smoking snorting blow
that was the darkest pain I had because
and after that I never bought into it
once I say betrayal is a trip betrayal
of close people to commit suicide you
know you think you know you do well here
this is gonna happen and no one ever
calls you you know I mean they tell you
a little story you do this you sign this
this is gonna happen except but it never
really happens to the degree which
typically tell you this is gonna happen
you know or your mind plays tricks on
you you know I never one thing I never
did was sell my soul I know who I was I
knew where I came from when I kept in
the back of my mind and that helped me
after a long as yard I had my little
bout with my [ __ ] and like I said
November 2007 I just stopped I had to
get a movie and the old producer said to
me that my reputation preceded me that
before I accepted this movie that I knew
I had to be on the set every day and
they knew I had some type of drug
problem so it embarrassed me so much
hmm I said I gotta give this up if I
want to move on you know and but I can
look like in the I can look myself in
the eye every [ __ ] day and know that
I did this calmly game I didn't have to
sell my soul you know that was I'm a bad
[ __ ] from The Comedy Store being
from The Comedy Store tell you so you
know it's very easy but no you are we
get confused at times I know when you
were a young man
they threw a lot at you at one time oh
man when you came from [ __ ] nothing
they do everything at you and I can't
tell you what you know when you think
about it now what you survived no I'm
very grateful but you know one sometimes
I see people who are blind I keep like
Stevie one even though he may been do
hard times I've been through divorce or
something imagine being able to see the
person that you love hurt you rate it
standing that [ __ ] I'm what does that
a stand and caught your imagine if a
black person could see that somebody
that you love said [ __ ] you he did this
to me in front everybody gets y'all yeah
it's over yeah I got a divorce soon men
fear this wife after my life with this
person I love the person every grain of
love and in my body in my mind
everything and this is what this comes
to it's two [ __ ] tearing at each other
like animals I love you Mike in my life
man you are you know people have to know
that when I started the podcast I didn't
do the podcast to be up here I want to
let people know that no matter what
happens to you you could get to you go I
left people don't believe in I don't
give a Frenchman's [ __ ] this is what you
want to do you could do it and I think
that you're helping a lot of people I
learnt that from custom never give up
never give up you know the prison system
is meant to break you mentally and
physically they tell you when you get
out of prisoner you could do paperwork
and go on disability to rest of your
life because you're a felon I ripped
that [ __ ] up for the strengthen people
if that's what it did to Manson people
for two years after my fella I thought I
got out of prison I had to do you know
background checks and people come back
to me a week later and say you got a
felony now good no I don't you got the
wrong Jose Diaz you know many
[ __ ] Jose Diaz is there is
that's like Josh Smith in Miami get the
[ __ ] out of my face and I would I never
addressed myself like a flower
I said I paid my dues to society I
didn't rat I [ __ ] did it I'm gonna
start anew
it took me because I'm a [ __ ] it took
me two years to get on stage laughter I
got the [ __ ] prison cuz I'm a [ __ ]
but once I did it I had my purpose and I
figured I'd go underground then I came
home one day and my wife said I don't
want to be married to you no more yeah I
knew as I you know I knew as I was
getting a letter she wasn't gonna let me
be a father to this child the boyfriend
I had - oh yes she left me for an older
guy like him that I couldn't blame or
money I found Mike Tyson Tyson think him
back today I don't blame her I don't
[ __ ] blame him I how can I be angry
at her she was thinking about that child
you know I think about when I leave a
child with me
when I was 32 years old for five hours
not really not really so she had every
right to do what she did I'm like I'm
like [ __ ] Denzel and man on fire I
had to give up a life to get a
[ __ ] life so tell me brother
it's kind of like you get conscious rate
of what you've done they're telling you
you weren't living your life right to
have the child to live with the child
how do you how do you learn to make up
to yourself I write I keep in touch with
everybody who helped me out as I was
growing up I keep the touch with all my
friends anybody who helped me along the
way I keep in touch I try to do
something nice for somebody every day
when I wake up make somebody's day is
what I call it there's nothing like
making somebody's day you ever got a
call from [ __ ] I don't want
nothing from you you just call up to
check up on your ass once twice a week
to call a [ __ ] go what's going
on don't text me either take that text
and shove it up your mother's ass
just call me I want to hear your voice
Mike
you know that that's definitely not a
problem we're dealing with them what I
want our children today or they won't
they won't call you this you have to
have you have to tell them my mother
[ __ ] mean is nice yeah you have to
still talk to people I'm a firm believer
in calling people what's up dog
I don't want nothing from kids you live
in a place where somebody's always
looking for something so when you get a
call from somebody just checking in with
you just to say so in all I think about
my mom and I think about my step that I
saw my stepdad shoot a dude on 148 and
Broadway the Santeria party one time he
was out Makua he was no no he grabbed me
by the hand we got in the car we went
down to Riverside Drive he threw the gun
into the Hudson we drove home and you
know what Mike we never talked about it
he even left my mother at the Santeria
party we never talked about it in 2006 I
started reconnecting with him like in 95
and I checked in with him and then I
realized that he was my stepfather and a
lot Who I am today is because of him and
when they were eating lunch in 2006 and
I look him in the eye and I go you shot
it was [ __ ] hilarious the guy's name
is nicko he owned the bar on the
forty-third and Broadway but he liked a
certain Cuban dish called B Kylie so
they called him Nico Pigalle and and my
stepfather didn't drink or do drugs he
just liked to shoot people he was a
religion in Cuba québécois there's
Santeria and then there's our Makua how
acquire those [ __ ] that they
walk around with a straight razor and
they dedicate their life to saying
Lazaro duh the saint with the dog buddy
cutting themselves no no no no no
[ __ ] cut you huh but the reason they
cut you is to demoralize you so slice an
ass cheek
you know it was [ __ ] cur they don't
need [ __ ] man only [ __ ] an interesting
guy they're interesting [ __ ] dude
it's like you know
you gotta listen if you're not eating
[ __ ] now you're not gettin no [ __ ]
yeah not even for start to look at high
school kids are doing this [ __ ] man you
got a push
keeps your loser tickets yeah yeah you
eat somebody's [ __ ] at a party MA
[Laughter]
well Joey I mean what do you think about
well Joey do you we eat after you put
your finger up the ass I'll tell you
what man I've been married I've been
with the same for mother for 18 years if
I try to stick a finger up her hand
she'll [ __ ] cut that [ __ ]
hand on them days are all worth on coke
freak days are over with you know that
was a long time ago Mike it's crazy how
you think back at the [ __ ] that you got
into when you were doing cocaine and I'm
embarrassed what I was doing coke you
know I wouldn't look in the mirror when
I was coked up I know I had I wouldn't
look in the [ __ ] mirror when I was oh
because I didn't want to see in my face
if you look at my face I have scars I
would pick ingrown hairs just to like in
other words it was like cutting cuz I
didn't like what the [ __ ] I was you know
but man I'm happy that's all over
I was always dehydrated and I never
drink after dij I would drink water with
the coke I never drink water as I ever
did I said if I drink water at least I'm
being half healthy then the next day I
would wake up and eat sushi Oh God let
me go eat sushi and if I eat the sushi -
sushi eliminate the cocaine from my
bloodstream and I could snort coke in
two days again I'm ready to rock that's
how crazy the addiction gets you're
[ __ ] high I'm doing cocaine I won't
stop if I get arrested again - accident
car accident I just won't stop somebody
had to stop me I couldn't stop on my own
I couldn't stop either Mike for years
like I said I was doing coke when I was
under like a probation program program I
couldn't stop
I couldn't stop I resorted to [ __ ]
pudding who puts chlorine on their dick
and that's a big way I don't know I did
that burn it burned it I still have
little [ __ ] scars on there from the
[ __ ] and then I put the other [ __ ]
dog the Drano to really [ __ ] up the
Michonne [ __ ] I always [ __ ] them up
in every single way they could every
time I would ignite dicker right now it
works yeah somebody's got a couple scars
will say Frankenstein's [ __ ] Foy but
you know I make it work got a scar too
hey it works bro oh you're not John
Babbitt no before you know John yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] me yeah and you met a lot
of people and they all love you and they
still love you Mike I'm very grateful
you know they're good people and good
people aren't cookies I saw it a couple
UFC fights and I'd see how people
reacted to you I tried to give a lot of
know they could see how no matter what
happened you know in your life you get a
lot of love Mike Tyson despite the color
where you from what happened people love
you man I just walked I just went up to
the story at night want to be real boys
is there yeah we had a good ever seems
like dog it was the best day of my life
Mike Tyson was so [ __ ] Kwame you know
what you're doing right now I mean is uh
it's [ __ ] tremendous man you know
when I was young after most of my used
in Los Angeles and I met a lot of people
just all kinds of people to great people
to wrong people if everybody enough and
I've had my share with all of them and
stuff and it was just wasn't healthy
mmm although it's burning the candles on
both in would you ever consider
moving back to New York now my wife
doesn't want to go back she lived in
there too didn't want to go out shopping
she likes those coals anymore it was
cool weather that um I wouldn't mind you
know I'm very interested in trying San
Francisco out that's a lot of people up
there yeah I like my Cisco I wanna in 85
I lived in San Francisco for about six
months
tell me about it well then like I lived
in the Tenderloin the mother Tenderloin
was the Tenderloin and I'm gonna be
honest to you Mike he's rough 1985 I was
a bartender at a club called Rock and
Robbins on Haight and Ashbury all the
way at the end across from Burger King I
think the Burger King or the McDonald's
is still there so at night I would have
to take the bus back to whatever the
[ __ ] Market Street mission whatever the
[ __ ] it was
I saw more violence in six months in San
Francisco in 1985
then I saw growing up in New York all
those years I saw a black dude and a
white dude fight and the white dude had
a stick and the brother had a sword holy
yeah white dude in the arm and there was
blood [ __ ] everywhere I saw another
guy stabbed open in front of original
Joe's in a tenderloin in 85 and this is
the best one where I was getting nickel
bags one day I go in there and there's a
bunch of cops and the cop said turn
around and leave they were waiting for
Rick who was this Night Stalker that's
what he was buying then that's where he
would stay at that hotel they took the
door from that hole Rick maroon the
Mitchard Ramirez yes they took the door
off because he wrote ACDC creeping along
yeah and then they beat him up when he
got off the bus Mexicans gotta [ __ ]
they knock told him to death right here
in the East LA somewhere then the
Congress in that neighborhood they had a
[ __ ] coffee shop called coffee runs
it was topless [ __ ] coffee you going
in there was chick stop let's all crack
hold up and [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
intravenous veins on that table because
I want to UM this is what I'm interested
in doing to it can
company you know in San Francisco they
had smoke shops their smokes please sit
down smoke you you can sit down to smoke
your weed we go wow wow yeah yeah yeah
Mike's got one of those are the works to
English looking around York laughing
Mike I mean like the same question goes
to you can you still believe you're 53
and tikkun I've know everything you went
through no I know when you wake up in
the morning tell me the truth do you
look up and say thank you Laurie
grateful give me another [ __ ] I do it
every day in the shower I'll tell you
something um after taking two I thought
I was tough you know I thought was a
tough guy you know I checked for people
from others you know all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] I realize I'm not tough at all I'm
happy the one kid didn't kill me you
know I'm very grateful very grateful
every day I'm grateful I was uh you know
I don't know I was never in the
territory you were in but I'm like I
said I'm just very grateful for being
here right now at this part of my life
you know I'm still active at The Comedy
Store
that's like [ __ ] I must be awesome right
yeah it could be 56 and they go to the
Tommy store no yeah it was a I've been
there for 22 years that was my only home
that was the only thing I had nobody
would talk to me but you know I was
doing the movies on my own you know for
for spider-man 2 I sent my own audition
tape I was a hustling like I used that
New York mentality casting directors
wouldn't see me The Longest Yard they
didn't want to see me so what did I
doing what the Houston I got all coked
up and I went to Play It Again Sports
and I bought a helmet for a [ __ ]
little guy like a 9 year old and I
bought a shirt I was 400 pounds then
well I bought a shirt that was an XL and
I had my tits out and I was thrilled and
I drew the ball and I did the lines from
the movie and I sent it to Adam Sandler
and they called me in for an audition I
got the movie that's how I hustle well
took it back New York style I used to
get the breakdowns and send emails to
the casting people so that's how I got
the hustle first and then my stand-up is
still too dirty whatever
and I started telling stories I dug into
telling these [ __ ] who the [ __ ]
I really was the podcast came along and
I told the story about being with my
buddies get an eight ball of coke one
night in a club in 1982 summer of 82 and
we're doing a couple one and in those
days if you went down 11th Avenue by
where the docks are it was all hookers
and they'd be out there in the summers
let you close this [ __ ] telling Mike
stop you wouldn't believe it he packed
because his pact is with the hook there
butt naked in the street in the streets
butt naked in the street the hunk of a
naked in the street you wouldn't believe
got see the believe you can and not they
wearing fancy clothes that butt-naked
my ass let you finger them you know just
leave that all time high man it was it
was it was [ __ ] crazy something like
5 in 80 I went on the flow you at the
walk step over them in the street just
step over people I went to go to the
ferry two months ago three months ago I
went back to New York and I go to a
ferry and I remember looking at it going
what was here 20 years ago why is he so
familiar to me that came back to me that
had that whole area was hookers so I had
a buddy that by every time I pick him up
he'd always go somebody's gotta suck my
dick tonight he would always say this
you can't believe a young beautiful girl
there but naked
nobody think you'll see some monsters
out there you seeing yeah girl and the
pimp was a black dude in a wheelchair
you thought was [ __ ] up but he had an
Uzi under his wheelchair I mean it was
[ __ ] dirty down there and my buddy
would always make a stop to look at the
hookers and then he would go right get
out of the car I'm gonna get my dick
sucked and he would get his dick
something to always be an argument but
Litton's brought this jet in the broad
open all you saw was cars cars and bacon
yeah there was a side street whether we
are nothing if it was like a
ramp and cars would just pull over and
you just see the cars shakin people yeah
driving it was like a [ __ ] busy time
at nighttime but you know it was like a
[ __ ] Museum in those days the hookers
would give you I think it was 25 for a
[ __ ] 50 for [ __ ] a [ __ ] if you
threw in the extra 10 and we're being
around the world they would eat you
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I swear to my mother's
grave I never touch one of those hookers
but my buddy was addicted to hook it
there was a place in New York called the
10/40 Club and this is a story for all
you young guys don't ever get in a car
with nobody go out by yourself when
people say I'm picking you up go [ __ ]
yourself I'm girl by myself and I got in
the car with this dude named Pedro his
family owned the candy company and they
had candy trucks and we went over to the
city for his birthday Thor the 10/40
Club
it was 999 plus tax 1040 and they'd rush
you into a room and there'd be two you
know those dudes that got Cologne on and
say how much [ __ ] they get all those
dudes would be in there drinking and
then they would open up a door and push
like 200 chicks I got like 20 chicks out
at a time and you had a grab and like
kick him in the ankle and then you had a
ticket and you had to give it to the guy
and he let you into a back and it was
just partitions you could hear people
[ __ ] next to you and they take a
bucket out from under the [ __ ] bed
like a ping pang pool mattress they take
a sponge out they wipe down your dick
and then they put a condom on you and
then the chicken I'll never forget I was
that was the first time I was a Catholic
I like suck some titties at that time
and maybe fingered some people but I was
not hip to sex at all and this chick got
on time when she took the stockings off
it was nasty and she got on top of me
and she started going back and forth and
I could hear my dick and her and it was
like I just can get the sick to my
stomach
and then she stopped after a minute Mike
and she looked at me she goes you know
for $10 extra you could eat my [ __ ] I
[ __ ] threw her off me I got my
clothes my clothes on and I [ __ ] him
went and I walked through the [ __ ]
bus and I never went to one of those
places ever [ __ ] again it was such a
horrible experience
but if in those days if you went down to
42nd Street you made a right a Broadway
there was all these bars and there would
be these dudes we were 14 that be these
dudes in front of these bars and they'd
go see naked women see naked women they
didn't give a [ __ ] they wouldn't give a
[ __ ] of you with ten you would go in
there you would sit down and then these
women would sit on your lap and then
they'd say okay honey we could make out
if you buy me a bottle of champagne well
they bring them one of those Paul Mooney
little bottles of champagne and they
wanted 40 bucks you 13 and you're like I
ain't got 40 bucks get the [ __ ] out of
here but you will go up and down
Broadway just feeling a little titties
is [ __ ] it's just for being 14 then they
had the peep shows where the windows
opened and you could stick your head in
the chick will let you suck at it for 60
cents Jesus Christ you and you tell
people these stories and they look at
you like Joey knock it off that's why
when they did the 75 people went crazy
that was an interesting show you got to
get him on the podcast my dad I got I'll
give you the digits I'll give you the
dude but my dad you know people think
that's was New York yeah that was it
that's 75 precinct that was every
[ __ ] precinct yeah that was you know
that it was a different way you know how
come gambling at in the end of 70s and
80s was a ticket New York City but it
was it's a felony in New Jersey right
across the [ __ ] bridge it was
programmed and how what they would do is
Mike's got a gambling no more Mike's got
a bank I 100 and 18th Street I'm a cop I
go see Mike every Friday he gives me 200
hours but Mike knows that every 90 days
Mike's gonna get a phone call go Mike
clean out your Bing that means have
$2,000 there and have a phone there so
when me and my six cops show up I
handcuffed Mike I take him down to the
station Mike gets a ticket and then I
meet Mike that night if Mike had two
grand in there I had to give a grand to
the other cops I give a grand back to
Mike and then Mike goes to court in a
month and I tell the cops not to show up
and Mike would go home it was a scanner
Michael just stood it
top of what he had to pay every 90 days
you gotta take a bust you gotta take a
bus that's just the way life is it was
such a it was so [ __ ] corrupt there
was a jungle man it was a jungle
sometimes it makes me wonder if it
really was the first name yeah how you
doing today Mike it was such a different
animal and to see that and try to
describe it to people what you do either
they mike snatch their purse you know
that you see politics today you see how
politics is now our people losing their
mind and [ __ ] like that
I saw corruption growing up my mom had a
bar two cops are coming once a week and
have a drink and my mom would give him
an envelope and they would leave and
that was just a part of doing business
we had an attorney in Jersey City all
right I'm an attorney with his name was
Sam DeLuca he's retired now Sam DeLuca
was a [ __ ] that you walked in
there Mike and he basically told you
Mike how you doing great to see you
champ champ here's the deal and Mike
Tyson you know your nominee plan is I
want in there because the bookmakers my
mother hung out with well huben so they
would make believe they didn't speak
English so I would always go with them I
would get the day off from school they
gave me like 100 bucks to go be the
interpreter between Sam DeLuca and this
guy and in those days the late 70s like
this is mid 70s I'd be like 12 and I'd
go down at the Lucas office and he'd go
hide no how's your mother good and then
the guy would sit down and go Mike
listen I just got a call the other day
from the DEA they want to give you a
year and want you to plead to them
simple assault but for $200,000 I'll get
you 90-day probation for a hundred time
and then they would give you like a menu
for $100,000 you can do 90 days for
50,000 you and 120,000 you gonna do 120
days call me no week and let me know
what you want to do that's how simple
the system was you know an hour in there
[ __ ]
minute you getting the only [ __ ]
miserable plate it was such a thing to
see growing up and now I go to this 42nd
Street I see Olive Garden yeah it's
beautiful now I see our God not for
industry they see what it was that we
can't really believe the best pool it's
really wretched den of iniquity
you don't know what it's like to do a
line of angel dust and go into the city
in the 8th grade play hooky and walk up
and down those streets either in it at
the end you just once I couldn't handle
any of this I can't take no [ __ ] what is
that like I know every [ __ ] Evan but
when it wears off is not over it comes
back and hits you again oh really it's
like a 12 hours ya trip and they would
call it crystal THC we came with all
these different names 2d rail the impact
of Oh Marilyn biscuits and angel dust
zoo dust and otherwise we would smoke it
they also in those days uses so joints
with formaldehyde in for like 12 bucks
you know how [ __ ] up the mouth dehyde
get you when you sweat it dip it in
there oh so [ __ ] up Joey what's it
like being a comedian these days in this
super sensitive
worried about climate might you know
that before you go into something if you
don't have a little bit of fear in your
stomach you might as well quit fear
always has to live there because that
fear you take it and that's what you
turn into your performance for Mike it
was knocking [ __ ] out and for
me it's timing precision focusing I'm
gonna have to say you know last night I
had to go out for the Comedy Store 27
years I'm doing comedy 10 minutes the
kid comes over to me and he goes you're
up in five minutes and it's like a
[ __ ] eternal time bomb and then you
go back to what Mike was saying I'm
following [ __ ] Russell Peters not
only the guy is a great comic on the
gentleman somewhere
and and Theo von I'm following Theo von
and Russell Peters and then it's five
minutes before four minutes and you
start thinking about all the bad things
you did you start thinking about do you
deserve this what the [ __ ] am I doing
here if these people really knew that
one time I went into a Carvel and took a
change and got $7 for it would they
still be laughing at my jokes you know
these people that come up to you after
one go line let's take a picture if they
knew that one time you put a gun in
somebody's waist would they still want
to take a picture these are all thoughts
that's coming to your [ __ ] head and
then with a minute left New York City
comes back into your Hoboken comes back
into me North Bergen you need a city and
I go what the [ __ ] am I talking about
who the [ __ ] am I scared of nobody
slap me loose on that [ __ ] stage and
you go you go up there you you you stand
your ground
you tell your [ __ ] joke from your
stomach through your heart it passes
through you lay the [ __ ] bomb out and
either they laugh or not and you jump on
them I got Mike style in the first round
in the main there's two rooms at the
Comedy Store the original room in the
main room in the main room it's more of
a theater room you could come out to him
you have to be bigger out there in the
original room you got to come out like
one of the biggies say you got to come
every night like Mike Tyson Jordan
Jackson you got to come out like Mike in
the [ __ ] original room because it's a
smaller ring and it's [ __ ] bigger
gloves its two-pound gloves it's 20 it's
32 ounce gloves so you got to come out
in the original cuz it's small and be
bigger so last night I had to do the
main room then the original room I had a
follow a Lee Wong Rogan you know so that
fear you need that fear I like I don't
like that doubt when it comes into my
mind Mike that [ __ ] [ __ ] with me a
little bit I ain't gonna lie to you that
doubt [ __ ] with me a little have it
though real have that but I always have
that doubt because of my past should I
be doing this if these people only knew
but it doesn't matter it's like I wrote
the
the caption doesn't matter where you
start is where you finish
if only in the own thick head that we
think we trash it my [ __ ] sick head
every night I think I'm a piece of [ __ ]
I am NOT but I towards being a better
[ __ ] every day along the way
especially the last 11 years this is
what I learned all my years really I
learned the piece of [ __ ] can't be
redeemed you're not a piece of [ __ ] well
thank you brother first no real trust me
all my life I thought the same but yeah
because she can't be redeemed brother
he's writing for rest of his life
getting that [ __ ] [ __ ] these
beautiful girls coming out of the blue
now [ __ ] I started getting these
beautiful girls supermodel actress Laura
I said [ __ ] they really like not forgive
me nor that [ __ ] [ __ ] full of
money when my alright I believe that
these people could really like my ugly
ass like it's funny I don't I don't put
that vibe out and I get it once in a
while on the road or something and I see
the move coming like I have a rule and
I've had a rule for years the
[ __ ] I don't come into my hotel
room I don't even like men in my hotel
room you want to come over so I'm me you
know hallway guys like you and I we grew
up in a house where there was no peace I
used to watch these white shows on TV
the Waltons
Ranjan family and I couldn't wait to
have a house like that and it never
happened for me and now today I had that
[ __ ] out incredible it's not a big
house I don't even own the [ __ ]
what I'm trying to tell you is my home
just what I wanted as a child there's no
yelling there's no screaming nobody's
yelling at 8:30 in the morning there's
no hot water left there's no anger in my
house I got cats I got a six year old I
talked to my wife in a certain tone she
speaks to me in that tone my wife was
there with me I put my wife in such a
[ __ ] 4
all we were dating that she took out a
loan for me that I had to pay back 636
dollars a month for six years and I paid
it back after I got off the cocaine so
by me trying to [ __ ] get a piece of
[ __ ] I leave my wife too much I need
this little six-year-old girl too much I
did that [ __ ] I feel in my life now to
the did this [ __ ] already I got my dick
sucked and what did it get me
divorce I got a thirty year old daughter
I won't talk to you Mike Tyson won't
talk to me Mike Tyson [ __ ] walk
around 30 years she won't talk to me
god knows what the mother told her
whatever I'm doing now doesn't justify
it you know what at this point in the
game what would it do if we talked it
would just bring up bad memories for her
and me and the mother and you know what
my house dog is is all those the Dick
Van Dyke Show my house is the Dick Van
Dyke Show the worst thing that happens
in my house is I smoke pot in my
bathroom in the back or i watch dark
clothes and I let her watch it with me
the six-year-old so she brushes up on
her Spanish you know saying I don't know
what I could do without my children they
were making I once stayed in my life
when I finished fighting kids didn't
have a good relationship me to fight
with the mother all the time cheat on
all the time so um they really never got
a chance to get to know me till I got
old in like 1920 where doctors finishing
college and so I started developing a
relationship with them and it's the best
thing that I've ever done and I hate to
lose that again you know other things I
don't say you know they're real liberal
have some kids that are real liberal and
you know you can't say the right thing
I'd be politically correct you can't say
the word [ __ ] or some [ __ ] like that
get ya something a [ __ ] you can't feel
those things around my daughter who I
love and I I don't care if that's that's
all I have to do for her love me and
care about me
I'm not gonna faint as those words you
know that's just the way that I think I
think take that fell for the like I
couldn't breathe when I wasn't havin
every relationship my children I feel
like I can't breathe I just can't deal
with that feeling I don't think I'm a
sucker at my age now I don't even know
why I need to be friends with my favor I
just I have to have them I you know I
battle with those feelings
[ __ ] I'm the father they should be
having a relationship with me I'm dad
they put them on the mother sent from
the college that they wanted to go to
their educate them to be all snooty the
way they are with me all right you know
I say that sometimes but it just um it
doesn't work that way you know you gotta
bow down sometime give up you know if
you're gonna be in their lives somebody
else could be in their life you're a
beautiful man I'm happy I came down here
today a man we're happy to you came
big-time man who the man brother the
[ __ ] is off Joey thank you so much -
thank you yeah really awesome so awesome
to have you brother come back and clean
so much please do we don't
thank you brother I feel you thank you
for what you've done I mean your pockets
are getting three million four million
dollar stuff I don't [ __ ] know no I'm
just
what's your pod called again Joey
Churchill what's happening now yes the
Church of what's happening generates on
[ __ ] Netflix you know I'm out there
yeah brother dinner it's a it's a series
they do that Netflix hopefully they'll
do it again they'll be a part of it or
something
I smell kicking ass out here yeah that
place is kicking [ __ ] ass
yeah thanks brother thank you for having
me good luck to everybody here much luck
too brother
thank you lots of love thank you all
right everybody Mike great show man man
Thank You ed man awesome guest that we
had here and I'm awesome what can I say
hey this is another
conclusion of hot Bachman I'm Mike Tyson
I'm having Britton I'm Joey Diaz and
we're out stay black peace
[Music]